This video is brought to you by ground news.
It's up wisecrack, socially distance, Jared here. Now,
if you're watching this chances are your life has recently been turned upside
down by the novel coronavirus COVID-19 is currently causing mayhem all over
the globe while biologists sociologists,
all of the ologists really are going to have plenty to say about this whole
thing in the coming years,
it's impossible to predict the full extent of the viruses impact.
All we really know is that the world will most likely look different when this
all shakes out that's because every epidemic or pandemic in history from the
black plague to tuberculosis to HIV has left a sizeable Mark on
humanity. Obviously there's the tragic death toll,
but diseases have also altered,
shaped and reshaped the course of social and political history.
Sometimes the connections are very literal.
Typhoid is speculated to have knocked out Alexander. The great,
the bubonic plague seems to fast-track the downfall of the Byzantine empire and
measles or smallpox likely did the same to the Roman empire,
but diseases have also kick-started everything from sexist morality laws to
public health infrastructure,
to rigorous government surveillance so much so that it's not a stretch to say
that diseases created the modern state. As we know it don't believe us.
We've got nothing but time to prove it.
So join us on this journey through the nasty microorganisms that have changed
human history in this wisecrack condition on how the plague created the modern
world.
But first, a quick shout out to.
Our sponsor, ground news, not unlike diseases.
The new cycle has definitely shaped the modern world.
Misinformation and hysteria can be as deadly in a pandemic as the disease
itself. And it's important to check the facts, health authority, guidelines,
and vetted information. Before you decide to loot stores for toilet paper,
between newspapers, cable coverage, and social media,
it's become harder and harder to make your own judgment on news stories.
These days,
luckily today's sponsor ground news allows you to audit the stories you read
online. So you can make an informed opinion.
The app allows you to view who has covered the same story and where they fall on
the political spectrum.
You can make your own judgment with less of a fear of being biased.
Ground news allows you to follow threads and keep track of all the coverage.
So you always know what is going on. The app is available on iOS or Android,
and it's free to download. It's a great tool to help you interpret your news.
So download it now by clicking the link in the description.
And now back to the show today,
we're going to focus on the bubonic plague because of the unique way it shaped
the modern world.
Now don't let the fun name fool you bubonic plague is a horrifically lethal
disease that mostly spreads by a flees who hang out on rats until they get the
chance to jump onto humans and chow down.
The plague has swept various countries and even entire continents throughout
history from ancient Byzantium to mid 19th century India to 21st century
Madagascar.
But we're going to focus on the second plague pandemic known as the black death,
which began in the mid 14th century,
like your dramatic roommates troubled relationship.
It was on again off again for approximately 500 years,
except it also killed up to percent of Europeans and didn't and didn't makeup
sex on your shared couch. Naturally, the plague generated terror, panic,
massive violence, and a surge in religiosity.
People desperately fled infected cities under the prevailing wisdom of the time,
which held that plague and other maladies were caused by me asthma or the
diseased air.
And all the gnarly smells that haunted city life societies were unprepared.
And physicians powerless in the face of an ugly as hell disease often becoming
sick themselves.
The Aras increased urbanization and meant more people lived in closer often
hygienic quarters,
which made it all the easier for fleas to jump from rats to humans to spread the
disease. Also increased international trade led to many rat-infested boats,
transporting spices textiles. And of course,
bubonic plague from country to country economies were decimated social order
overthrown. The works take Naples,
which had nearly half its population wiped out by the plague of 1656 as
scholar Frank Snowden writes in his book, epidemics and society.
Every activity of normal life ceased admits shuttered shops, unemployment,
hunger, Snowden depressingly notes that after a while,
too few people were left alive, Ariel,
the dead throughout Europe suspected sinners,
typically Jews and other religious dissenters forerunners accused witches and
sex workers were banished or even murdered by very scared,
very dumb vigilantes,
real and governmental systems knew they had to act fast.
Thus began with Snowden calls.
The first form of institutionalized public health in 15th century,
Northern Italian city States. That meant drafting plagued regulations,
which anointed new health magistrates who provided with full legislative
judicial and executive powers in matters related to public health by
the 16th century. In some cities,
these initially temporary posts had grown into permanent agencies that
is boards of health.
These efforts would according to Snowden Mark a vast extension,
an upstate power industry peers of human life that had never been subject to
political authority,
such extensions ranged from the regulation of butcher meat to the forest
quarantining of entire populations.
And this the office of health created two Lazaretto shows or not very mellow
islands were ships coming from the Eastern Mediterranean were brought to be
disembarked and fumigated again because they thought disease was spread through
bad smelling air, hundreds of less than stoked pads.
We're then isolated and guarded for 40 days,
which would become known as a quarantine after the Italian word for 40.
This number incidentally was chosen because in Christian scripture,
40 is associated with purification.
Moses was on Mount Sinai for 40 days before receiving the 10 commandments Christ
was tempted for 40 days.
Christ stayed with his disciples for 40 days after his resurrection, et cetera.
So basically super solid science stuff, as dumb as this was,
it also happened to work because the incubation period of bubonic plague was
shorter than 40.
Once the practice was found to be apparently effective in quelling the spread in
Venice, other European ports followed suit. Of course,
there were still the threat of plague being spread by travelers on land,
which vigilante groups tried to STEM by violently patrolling city walls.
This practice eventually became regulated with troops being deployed to form
sanitary, cordons, IE,
military barriers that stopped goods and people from entering and forced them
into adorable 40 day timeouts.
One coordinate in Austria was a thousand miles long required,
mandatory service of basically all male peasants and lasted 161
years as scholar Mitchell, Hammond summarizes in his book,
epidemics in the modern world.
These kinds of actions became integral to the modern notion of a functioning
state that assumed responsibility for the protection of borders and the
preservation of health among citizens, Hammond,
even argues that concerns about plague began to override concerns about
independence among Italian city States leading to widespread cooperative efforts
to STEM the disease. But of course it wasn't just enough to keep people out.
There was also the threat of plague spreading within a city,
which is where things get fascinatingly bleak.
Sanitary authorities took draconian measures to prevent the disease from
spreading. They hired tons of municipal officials to locate plague victims,
transport them to [inaudible] and bring corpses to plague burial grounds.
[Inaudible].
This was an intense process picture,
often drunk searchers and body clearers barging into ship.
Your seriously ill roommate off to some random Island plus in Venice around two
thirds of Lazarus auto patients died. So this was for all intents and purposes,
a likely death sentence. And if you did survive, you'd be charged for the stay.
A litany of other rules, dotted various cities,
including forcing pet owners to kill their beloved fluffy friends who were seen
as potential sources of disease,
which is the single satisfact I have ever learned.
Other restrictions ranged from forbidding folks from selling clothes to banning
all public gatherings.
Sometimes isolation methods were taken were in the house of a sick person,
was marked with a red cross. And in England wrote the phrase,
Lord have mercy upon us.
Then the sick person and their entire household were forced into confinement
without any option for medical care and left to die.
So salient is the example of plague towns,
birthing modern power structures that philosopher Michel Fuko called a town
under plague and exceptional disciplinary model. In other words,
it was like a laboratory for the government's exercise of social control,
citing 17th century, French archives for co details.
The way local governments separated each plague,
written town into districts and those districts into quarters and those quarters
into roads in a new process of segmenting public space.
Then there was the literal organization and segmenting of people.
Every person in town was required to register themselves in centralized records.
Then they had to go get provisions and head into which meant basically never
leaving the house,
not even to walk your dog long before CCTV or the NSA
Fuko argues that it was here.
That government surveillance was born in each town.
A road supervisor called a syndicate would collect the keys to every house on
his block and lock the door from the outside.
Like a prison guard syndics would make daily row calls at each house.
They'd call out the name of each inhabitant,
who one by one went to the window to describe their current health condition.
It was best to be Frank because lying about your fever could get you the death
penalty lease chill of all breaking quarantine was,
and I can't stress this enough punishable by death who co notes that under
these extraordinary circumstances, inspection functions, ceaselessly,
the gaze is alert everywhere, stuck within the four walls.
If you're probably should be 17th century home,
every move you made was subject to supervision,
a tactic that was entirely unfamiliar privacy vanished under these conditions.
As every status update about your health went into the town's permanent records
as Fuko notes.
The plague has met fi order its function is to sort out every possible
confusion in the process,
such extreme measures make each individual subject to an omnipresent and
omniscient power. Thus, according to Fuko,
public health efforts ultimately were born and sustained as a means of
controlling urban space and the environment and expanded political power
drastically Fuko notes that some of the practices employed in plague towns could
be related to the way people with leprosy were treated when they were banished
to leper colonies.
The big difference though is rather than persecuting a select unfortunate few
fighting. The bubonic plague meant segmenting all of society,
which arguably resulted in a much more significant proliferation of power.
Creating what Fuko called the utopia of the perfect city with perfect here.
Meaning perfectly controlled.
Following these sorts of efforts by the 18th century,
plague did essentially disappear from Europe. So draconian laws worked right.
Well,
maybe Snowden notes that these policies were probably only one aspect of what
stopped the disease with other aspects,
including changes in climate hygiene and hypothetically genetic mutations.
However, because these laws were typically heralded as the chief cause of Europe
salvation, they have been frequently replicated.
Their parents' success has in more recent pandemics resulted in governments,
behaving objectively by forcibly detaining people,
surveilling them and otherwise extinguishing their civil liberties. And no,
we don't mean just by closing all the IHOPs during the third plague wave at the
end of the 19th century,
colonial Britain attempted to enforce such measures in plague Britain,
Bombay with the draconian zeal that it ignored local religious,
cultural and medicinal practices.
They divided sick people from their families and burned infected houses to the
ground in what Snowden calls public health by eviction and destruction.
So brutal was the effort that it caused half the population to flee thus
paradoxically spreading the disease further because again,
traveling fleas around the same time over in the States,
Chinese Americans were also ordered into quarantine with harsh laws that the
courts eventually overturned.
So plagues cause intense laws that when carried out badly can seriously
infringe on life and Liberty.
What are we supposed to make of the fact that now many of us are in complete
lockdown first off, just so we're clear. Stay the F home,
no one is burning down houses yet.
In which case we'd probably complain in times like these it's also worth
considering the fact that the plague didn't simply consolidate government powers
and enable abuse. They've also caused some pretty positive changes in society,
such as contributing to the lower-class uprising in England that eventually
ended feudalism to fostering a nationalist sentiment in India that would
eventually lead to the country's independence from colonial control.
What's more the plagues role in strengthening the modern state.
Isn't all bad either because that state gives you drinkable water paved roads
and is a pretty big player in the whole not dying of smallpox thing.
All that said it's hard to know what the effect of COVID-19 will be while
bubonic plague is kind of the Woodstock of infectious diseases.
Other epidemics have also catalyzed their fair share of social change.
Simplest once known as the POCs created huge stigmas around sex work and laws to
ban smallpox introduced by Europeans obliterated indigenous populations in the
Americas forwarding any successful resistance to colonization a smattering of
diseases like cholera and typhoid created public health concerns that led to
widespread adaptation of indoor plumbing and urban areas.
And weirdly enough tuberculosis,
which spread by coughs provoked fears over hygiene,
leading some to speculate that tubercular bacteria could hang out in a dude's
beard or mustache as a result,
facial hair tragically disappeared from turn of the century America for a time.
At least what's ultimately so fascinating and also scary about diseases is
the unintended ways they change our perceptions of society health,
and even our bodies while we're plenty grateful for government run indoor
plumbing,
it's still pretty weird to realize that much of the way the state gets involved
in our day-to-day lives,
stems from the terror and desperation caused by infectious diseases.
But what do you think, why is crack?
Can we blame bubonic plague for all our issues with authority?
What legacy should we expect? COVID-19 to leave in its wake and above all.
When will I be allowed to leave the house again?
Let us know what you think in the comments, stay safe, healthy, and sane.
And before you go,
I want to give one last shout out to ground news for sponsoring this video.
Ground news is the first news comparison platform that allows you to see where
your news comes from.
You can track stories and coverage to stay up to date with everything going on
in the world.
It's a great tool to help you interpret your news and read coverage across the
political spectrum.
The app is available on iOS and Android and free to download.
So check it out today,
thanks to all our patrons for supporting the channel and our podcasts.
Don't forget to subscribe and as always, thanks for.
Watching guys. Peace.
[inaudible].